V této kapitole poskytneme rámec
pro přemýšlení o počítačových prostředích
které lze aplikovat jak na tvůj laptop
tak škálovat až na superpočítače
na konci této kapitoly
pochopíš základní koncept počítačových zdrojů
a jak spolu vzájemně souvisejí
tak co jsou vlastně počítačové zdroje jednoduše řečeno
jsou to komponenty ze kterých se skládá počítačový systém
máme CPU neboli centrální procesor
který vykonává většinu instrukcí a máme paměť
neboli RAM která dočasně drží data
a instrukce programu
a máme GPU neboli grafické procesory
které jsou navrženy pro vykreslování grafiky
ale lze je použít i pro obecné výpočetní úlohy
vyžadující hodně paralelního zpracování
jako jsou vědecké simulace analýza dat nebo strojové učení
tyto zdroje spolupracují při vykonávání programů
a každý má své vlastní měrné jednotky
například jednotky CPU se měří v jádrech
a taktech zatímco paměť se měří v bajtech
v giga mega a terabajtech
pro každý z našich problémů
budeme potřebovat sadu zdrojů
pro jejich vykonání
je důležité zvážit zdroje potřebné pro jejich efektivní spuštění
umístění kde jsou komponenty programu spouštěny
a šířka pásma infrastruktury která je propojuje
hrají důležitou roli
při určování celkového výkonu
například GPU může být rychlé pro výpočet určitých částí
našeho programu ale pokud nahrání programu do paměti GPU
trvá déle než ušetříme
může být rychlejší použít místo toho CPU takže teď
pojďme si promluvit o škálování klasických zdrojů
máme dva přístupy vertikální škálování
a horizontální škálování vertikální škálování zahrnuje navýšení
výkonu jednoho zdroje
například použití výkonnějšího CPU nebo přidání více paměti
v rámci jednoho fyzického uzlu
přičemž uzel je jednotka výpočetního clusteru zapouzdřující více
zdrojů horizontální škálování
zahrnuje přidání více zdrojů
jako více CPU nebo GPU
které spolupracují na jednom uzlu nebo více uzlech
oba přístupy mají své výhody
a nevýhody a volba závisí na konkrétním případu použití
a požadavcích pojďme představit nový typ zdroje
kvantové zdroje kvantové zdroje zpracovávají kvantové informace
pomocí kvantové procesorové jednotky neboli QPU QPU
je celý systém zodpovědný
za přijímání spustitelné kvantové instrukční sady
neboli quantum circuit a vrácení
přesné odpovědi to znamená
že QPU obsahuje jeden nebo více kvantových čipů
například IBM Quantum
jakož i několik dalších komponent
v dilučním chladiči
který obklopuje kvantový čip
jako jsou kvantové zesilovače řídicí elektronika
a klasický počítač potřebný
pro úlohy jako je uchovávání instrukcí
a průběhů v paměti akumulace výsledků
a budoucí dekódování opravy chyb
obecně se kvantové zdroje měří
z hlediska jejich kvality škály vrstvené věrnosti
počtu quantum bits
a rychlosti operací vrstev circuit za
sekundu neboli CLOPS dnes budeme považovat kvantový čip
za měrnou jednotku podobně jako systémy správy zdrojů
zacházejí s GPU ne podle počtu jader
ale jako s celou jednotkou co teda škálování
podobně jako u klasických zdrojů lze škálování kvantových zdrojů
také rozdělit na vertikální
a horizontální vertikální škálování
by znamenalo zvyšování počtu qubitů na chiplet
nebo na čip
horizontální škálování by znamenalo propojování čipů
pomocí couplerů nebo klasických propojů
teď když máme tuto definici z cesty
pojďme si promluvit o správě zdrojů
správa zdrojů v počítačové infrastruktuře odkazuje
na proces plánování
přidělování a řízení využití výpočetních zdrojů
jako jsou CPU paměť úložiště
a šířka pásma sítě pro zajištění efektivního
a účinného využití zdrojů
správu zdrojů si můžeš představit
jako vícerozměrnou hru Tetris kde bloky
jsou požadavky tvé úlohy a
každá dimenze je jednotka zdroje obecný úkol
je vložit tyto bloky úloh do krychle
všech tvých dostupných zdrojů správa zdrojů
je velmi složitý úkol a různá výpočetní zařízení implementují
různé taktiky pro konfiguraci své infrastruktury
pro specifické potřeby svých uživatelů
pro uplatnění konceptů které jsme se právě naučili budeme používat
Slurm Slurm je open source software
pro správu zdrojů
pro demonstrační účely
mám lokální nastavení se třemi virtuálními uzly
informace o těchto výpočetních uzlech
můžeme získat spuštěním příkazu scontrol
máme dvě partition neboli skupiny uzlů
normal a quantum partition normal se skládá z uzlů
které mají přístup pouze ke klasickým zdrojům
a partition quantum má přístup ke kvantovým zdrojům
začněme nejprve jednoduchým
klasickým příkladem hello world se Slurmem
nejprve potřebujeme samotný program hello world.
A tady je náš program který jen tiskne hello
world.
Teď musíme sdělit správci zdrojů
jaké zdroje potřebujeme pro spuštění tohoto programu
jak jsme probrali Slurm poskytuje způsob jak specifikovat
veškerá metadata pro úlohu pomocí
skriptu což je jen shell skript
s některými Slurm-specifickými anotacemi
tyto anotace ti umožňují specifikovat požadavky na zdroje
parametry plánování a další.
Můžeme zkontrolovat náš submission skript
a tady máš specifikaci partition
kolik uzlů potřebujeme kolik úloh na uzel budeme
spouštět kolik CPU na úlohu použijeme
a jaký skript chceme spustit
a toto je náš program hello world.
Pro odeslání naší úlohy ke spuštění stačí spustit
jeden příkaz kterým je sbatch
a předat náš skript jako argument
můžeme zkontrolovat frontu spuštění
a vidíme že náš program hello world běží
na partition normal na uzlu c1
jakmile je úloha dokončena můžeme zkontrolovat výsledky
podívat se na výstupní soubor.
A to je vše.
Máme také zájem o využití kvantových zdrojů
proto pojďme vytvořit jednoduchý program hello Qiskit.
Tady je náš Qiskit program který obsahuje všechny
potřebné kroky vytvoření circuit
optimalizaci spuštění a post-processing.
A tady jsou všechny programovací koncepty o kterých jsme mluvili
quantum circuit transpiler
a Qiskit primitives
teď musíme vytvořit submission skript
jako předtím ale tady specifikujeme
požadavky na kvantové zdroje
protože jsme specifikovali zdroje
a partition celého clusteru
jaké kvantové zdroje jsou dostupné
Qiskit primitives použijí
přidělené zdroje pro spuštění kvantových výpočtů.
Teď musíme spustit náš program.
A jakmile je úloha hotová můžeme zkontrolovat výsledky.
A tady je naše očekávaná hodnota.
A to je vše ke správě zdrojů
v další části si budeme povídat
o programovacích modelech